previously we discussed the thermi and
argument and I wanted to come back to it
for a bit because I actually just kept
writing and writing and writing and
writing and writing and y'all had some
great comments and insights so let's
come back and look at a variant specific
to video games I don't have a witty name
for this one but the core idea is the
same it simply substitutes the game
mechanics for in-universe explanations
ie things that exist at the game layer
rather than things that exist of the
story layer for example a hypothetical
game let's call it assassin 47 lets you
kill strippers and drag their bodies
around assassin 47 is then
hypothetically criticized as
contributing to a pervasive trend in
culture where sex workers are treated as
disposable and the hypothetical game is
just one more tick in a very very long
tally and at this point you should keep
in mind how many times in your life you
have heard the phrase dead hooker in
response to this hypothetical fans of
assassin 47 and says that this is unfair
because when you kill a stripper in game
you lose points while this is not
treating the game as a historical
document it belies the same underlying
root values and ideas the appeal is
simply made to the mechanics rather than
to the world-building there is an
underlying logic there for the criticism
is supposedly rendered invalid this
speaks to the same priorities as with
the theremin argument the end product is
fine as is provided it is internally
consistent a soft penalty is sufficient
acknowledgment of impropriety and the
role of the text as part of a larger
pattern is considered on your relevant
detail the internal integrity of the
text is treated as functionally sacred
it's a kind of Orthodox
compartmentalization like Moses
forbidding the mixing of meat and milk
story elements ought to be argued
against story elements mechanics ought
to be argued against mechanics moving
that scrutiny outside its designated
space is treated as profane because this
can get messy and complicated very fast
as demonstrated in the Thera me and
argument video it's important to drill
down to the root exchange as many people
pointed out both the therapy and
argument and its game rules sibling
actually argue past the criticism that
they respond to there are in these
exchanges to conversate
going on the first being criticism of
some element or another and the second
being a rejection of the act of
criticizing when someone says it's all
okay because assassin 47 docs points for
killing strippers they're not saying
that a point loss makes the game not
sexist they're rejecting the notion that
the question why is this here even needs
to be asked in the first place this
process of appealing to rules or to an
in-universe explanation is really just a
ritual or a token that's why the theorem
Ian's arguments tend to be flimsy and
mercurial it's not about the criticism
it's about the act of criticizing the
therapy and argument then is more akin
to casting a vote than engaging in a
discussion this resistance to certain
forms of critical analysis isn't limited
to depiction of sex work and other
politically charged topics either it is
broadly applied to any criticism that
breaks the quarantine take for example
the idea of ludonarrative dissonance if
you haven't heard the term before or
have heard it being tossed around with a
snickering grin but don't know what it
means it can be best defined as moments
in a game where the mechanics and rules
and point systems disagree with the
story or encourage behavior counter to
the story's tone and themes the ludo
narrative is in a phrase the story told
by the game's mechanics let's say
assassin 47 starts the game with a long
monologue about how every life is
valuable and killing is a terrible evil
but maybe sometimes it's justified even
then who should have the power to choose
who lives and who dies
who can we trust with that judgment then
in game if you get enough headshots you
unlock the sniper scope that can see
through walls
that's ludonarrative dissonance the
story tells you to kill as few people as
possible while the mechanics encourage
you to go hog-wild so you end up with a
cutscenes story about the value of life
and a gameplay story about being the
worst spree killer since port arthur
push back against this kind of critical
engagement with games in particular has
become vogue in certain reddit gaffe
Qian type forums circles
terms like ludonarrative dissonance are
tossed around derisively as dog whistles
mocked for perceived hoity-toity excess
it's a sub cultural shorthand for
pompous overthinking
pointless waste of time essays and God
it's just a game can't you just play it
and have fun while this attitude speaks
directly to a vein of anti intellectual
hostility in certain subcultures it's
actually a lot bigger and more important
than that these little examples rapidly
spiral out into bigger questions about
the way that we as a society engage with
media and the value that we place on
awareness about that media we are now at
a point where the average individual has
instant access to more media more
culture than has ever been available at
any other time in human history we take
in more stories than ever before this
type of argument this cross
communication speaks to deep values
about the way that we collectively think
about our own culture and the way that
it and us all fit together while it's
easy to look at the type of individuals
who actively sandbag criticism and
suggest that they are an unambiguous ill
that is perhaps missing the forest for
the trees the root sentiments like it's
just a game stop thinking about it so
much aren't exclusive to youtubers with
skull avatars so thank you for joining
me on this little mini adventure through
some dense jargon strewn waters this is
still very much just scratching the
surface of some very big issues but I'm
going to leave you here to go in peace
my children in the name of like share
and subscribe
amen